[Music]
chiman in the showing and my 30th PhD
student at Stanford working in a
collaborative area and we've been
working on or accelerated in advance the
motivation for this project is that
quantum data applications and it
combined any discharge process and
whatever reason markets so if we just
take my Python data stack for example
you know a typical application to load
some using pandas straight over to
infinity model using sidekick learn and
maybe do something wearable process
anyway this is really great you can
dilemma racial worth of thousands of
people across the world who've never met
they're all avoiding other advanced
algorithms each of these domains they
just all kind of see it once we work
together with others but a kind of
negative of this is that there's no
optimization across functions right
you're not trying to buy into this one
framework you're taking these individual
libraries that you're stitching them
together and that actually reads a bunch
of performance on the table the fact
that you can optimize across individual
function flavors okay so how bad is this
problem how bad is it that we can't
optimize across these you know destroy
the function policy so it turns out that
the growing gap between the time the
case to your access to memory and you
know speed of our CPUs and all these
beginning devices every now is making
the traditional way of combining
functionality networks and
this is Italy the way that my
functionality today is just by you know
making functional
super simple example here we're using
canvas to parses the SP that drop some
values and computer meeting you become
fine right so there's one of one other
each of these functions and has an
umpire are written in so this isn't like
pipeline toward SS like pretty on
different functions but you could have a
better design for what's happening here
you have something ganas sitting around
in memory you call this party s new
function which Mike walks through you
know all your values and produces a new
results and you'll call this drop at
anything produces another result and the
finally you get an answer that you want
to get and it turns out that doing this
repeated accesses it you know doing none
of the obvious confetti we doing
something like C which is writing a
single loop that does all these things
on each other and kind of determine if
slowdown in you know applications using
dumb pipe and even things like tensor
flow which are in C++ and have these
specialized compilers compared to you
know same kind of engine optimized
implementation respect over concern can
be bare metal parts you there's a ton of
performance left on the table when we're
using these existing records this is
kind of the you know state of the art
designs to get in substance right you go
and install something using it and you
sketch together all these libraries do
you kind of get the job done but you're
not something working you observe all
these performance issues of pipelines
even if they're proposing these fast
data science tools and when you Hannah -
of engineers to optimize your pipeline
and leverage to either zoom in at
Stanford you know we have my people
and some people systems so you know
machine learning people come up with
these modular homes they read something
cool about assistants will come along
well if vision is that in continued that
first step and you get their little
performance for the other boss that's
kind of what we're going for here right
you install some pin package and these
optimizations kind of happen
automatically and you know you don't
really need to spend that much time like
squeezing or perform inside of your
article and I'll just get it without any
changes to the API didn't go bad that's
great okay so well does this optimizing
a lot of time that tries to achieve this
goal okay so kind of to exemplify them
though exemplify the performance that
wealth could give us some data set
computing a linear model and aggregating
of cubic disease which is again written
in C so if we just run this natively
using you know standard kind of my
limitations
this thing's like we're gonna live
weather like tens of yourself using well
well it can actually look at the entire
program and kind of generate code and
like a gentle pilot for each budget so
just with this code generation you get
migratory next because of things like
safety instructions and my other
compiler optimizations if you're not
using a result eliminates test result
and so far well the council fused
individual calls into you know every
single
so in that example we saw before we were
making these you know repeated passes
over the data well if you kind of see
that you're doing that infuse things
into like a single loop within each
library so that will do it for now mine
for pandas and at fusion Kevin gives us
like an a text you know over the native
relations kind of the magical element of
that you can actually optimize across
these white
as well so if you do something in online
is it can take those two computations
and kind of fuse them together so you
get kind of one end to end optimized
program and that is the plenty 9x to be
done over there- the wind asian right so
we're letting this none a second we
started with rapid or there's like fifty
signature and finally a couple of about
how this kind of happens with big for
greater and pop but well there's a
purely parallel runtime so anything that
you can express and well you can
actually parallel wise to your multiple
cores are you fishing for example so if
we enable up multi-threading on a single
or development machine you get a 180 and
speed up with no changes to the
application i'm compared to native
applications
this one makes like eliminate those like
prospect read memory movements co-opt
amazing across library calls generate so
overall long pinnable focus there's none
comment when x Bachelor of is and you
have these kind of domain-specific
libraries just simple machine learning
algorithm libraries that all kind of
targeted well and then well then it
generates code for these parallel
basically give other platforms tom
poston talk allows you to use today we
also have a prototype GPU and FPGA
implementation so if you're interested
and there's a bit about kind of looks
like this so kind of the core world is
this ir so the higher is just like a
small programming language and it's a
lot of problem in which that might keep
our are people are it's actually
something that can generate
away from libraries and then having to
give this one-time yu-gi-oh discuss both
of these pieces in more detail when you
generate this IR and once you have like
these little high R value is coming from
individual libraries you can run an
optimizer on it and then use a back-end
to generate like LLVM and accessibility
code and then you actually pass your
data into that and a compiled binary and
that's what you're into this okay so for
the rest of this talk I'll discuss the
runtime api which is how application is
kind of steep to well what's this is
wings have a library speed well and one
of the main tenants of all is that
applications themselves don't have to
change you kind of change the
implementation of the library but the
user facing application ATP I guess I
need to change they don't talk about
love the high bar which is have
applications
Express computation develop cement will
do a breakdown okay so the Wells 1/10
API uses winsy evaluation to collect
work across disparate wipers I think
this picture of a kind of sums it up you
have some user application that's making
all these function calls into different
libraries these are doing philology
regular platform they would kind of file
off one at a time you pass the result of
one call to the next one back again with
whether each of these calls is actually
emitting a little fragment of this world
code and that well code is kind of
communicated to what I was using the
month idea so internally well is kind of
building up a computation and when you
do something like print your result or
you know you want to write your result
is for something basically whether we
need testing we'll get your result in
some way well I'm kind of knows that you
need to do that
those individual hi are magnets together
into an optimized program and the
letters optimizer to do these things
like fusing loops and then combine them
combined into machine code and that's
what the name and your application
actually interact okay so a little bit
more detail without well this is kind of
the walkability right so the union of
squares or just math and stuff which is
a reduction in that square with so this
is similar to the victory solder there
we have some data sitting around in
memory you call this a math function
that you produce a new everything called
squares and then you do sin square boobs
and to get the final result we have 12
you have as well object thing that is
kind of the internally build another
lapidation
so you're distorting the fact that
you're going to revive a math followed
by the square root and when you like
print out the summer or whatever you get
this optimized program and you're kind
of just producing this one single stuff
you're not putting using these
intermediate results so you evaluate the
program once and you get a better
performance but you're gonna have to do
allocate water chunks of memory you
produce these results here so okay okay
well the study component is IR and this
is actually how you express the
computation I do want to do so that I
understand is that I can meet three
high-level goals the first of all it's
just a generality so we want to support
a diverse network was your people are
doing everything from machine learning
to prevent already X to zero and you
know pipeline cities would want to be
able to support all these things and
also want to be able to support but
nesting anything that's a few for every
element if you want to you know like
feature extraction routine
able to support that second we want the
ability to express optimizations so well
it's kind of goal is to be able to find
things that vectorization so we want the
guy to be able to express this operation
and the mental ball needs to be split up
in parallel and target parallel hardware
and this goal just comes from the fact
that you are harder it is getting
increasingly internal also designing a
language like this in 2018 that doesn't
target is kind of our okay so internally
the IRS actually made simple in some
sense says there's only two main
constructs there's other things that
going to take and if statements all that
basic stuff but the crux of the i/o is
really these two main projects
the first one is this parallel for loop
this is just a for loop that what we see
iterates over the dataset in parallel
and the second construct is this thing
called a filter which are these
declarative objects for producing
results so what is that it means that
within the IR and stuff you're not
actually specifying how you do something
about that
thanks of their money say something like
a pen data to a little computer some or
computer group buy or make a dictionary
or something like that but the
military's expensive on how these things
and then what this means that you can
actually implement them very differently
on different hardware builders also have
this additional restriction that you're
not allowed to use from them until
you're done with all your rights to them
so it's slightly kind of pull but
basically what that means is you don't
have to worry about things like walking
or in the IR but you don't have to worry
about oh is it still there logged when
I'm iterating over it in parallel can
you know this thread access a while it's
closed other than is doing something on
it it just makes doing is not to my
patients like group fusion extremely
simple organizer and you can just
implement a set of pattern matching
rules and at the backend for actually
generating low-level code will take care
of things like synchronization of
actually implementing these builders
okay so that's this right before reads
minutes and we've done that just these
two kind of core constructs can capture
everything from relational algebra led
to the functional API subscribing so Map
Reduce goodbye all this great stuff and
it's parkashoff is you know you've ever
built upon men is nothing like a grease
may use just from 20 years apart
bring your algebra and most importantly
also capture a composition of all these
points okay it's a different example of
what this IR kind of looks like I'm here
some functional operators using builders
base this is a map functions you're
getting this function at been applied
into every data element of data so this
is builder we're screening a new little
radio
which is just a pending items to a list
so note that we're not actually
specifying how items are coming to a
list right so there's actually a lot of
fluff under a pendant that goes on
because I'm going to do this in parallel
there's some synchronization you know
together and so forth but we're not
specifying how that happens at the
higher level this for loop is occurring
in parallel like we're doing the numbers
operation so average just means put
something in the middle there's this is
our writing into the Builder so we're
just verging f of X which is you know
when I'm appetizing to the Builder and
then the result is what kind of needs
the result out of the Builder this is
saying that we're done with all our
rights you know a stem will elect the
pieces that you got on multiple threads
or whatever and give us that result so
that's kind of what kind of commits the
Builder and gives you back your finances
to implement a reduced operation and it
looks very similar we're just changing
the builder comes from a Pender
converter and we're just just a bear
that there's a few other builders in the
language to be drinking from the
dictionaries to these groups so some
example optimizations that Wells can do
we have this example here we're
computing a map over some data followed
by a reduce on the same data right so
we're traversing over this data vector
twice in well this is kind of expressed
using just these four loops there's one
handed unified construct before a little
to Trevor so the data and then these
builders to kind of creating results so
instead of making two loops we can
actually identify that oh we're doing
two rows of the same data let's just you
know apply some pad national network
to a single and create two result at
once
as we have a single for loop and we just
merged to resolve into these two
different builders so you're getting
your results and you can see here that
we support things like that translation
and I are too so we're actually using
like a Scindia value here to the loser
merged into one task for the day and I
press ok so this is just a laundry list
of other features that we have it is a
research project but we're working fire
touch they make it usable so one thing
that we're you know really focusing on
is people want to use this it should be
easy to debug so we have all these great
lovely features ranging from an
interactive Red Bull for debugging a
bunch of blogging ability policy
functions we didn't even have some next
time waiting for them so I invite people
to try it out ok implementation wise
well the API is in C and Python with
Java support coming soon so you can
build up these well the computations
using you know C anti-black function
calls and enjoy me don't do some magic
to stitch these computations together
and all the compiler writer stuff is
kind of hidden away from the user so
there's a full level of the interface in
Kiev activism where an actual compiler
itself is written in around during
definitely depressed
nice big language with no runtime but I
guess the best stuff is kind of hidden
away from the most users of this is it
really the point of interaction for most
users will be able to see invited guests
and finally we have partial prototypes
of pandas at Empire return just as
prototypes intensive low-end spark with
well kind of integrated this is like a
sunset
- okay so okay so okay so we'll do some
results this first kind of results the
showing kind weld can accelerate
existing libraries random source and so
on PVC ages kind of this standard
benchmark that Hannah based folks use
for evaluating alumni performance in
abeyance marks Ebola with morality was a
3.5 Eckstein upon these two queries and
this is compared against perhaps equal
to point one which has this Java native
code generation already these speed ups
are basically coming from the fact that
we're generating much media assembly
code basically that's vectorized as
opposed to java was just generating Java
bytecode
speed-up it's almost entirely from for
non high on this black Scholes reporters
this financial making what we see a four
point five x beta and this is from
fusing loops together so now I'm a
little by default you know run each kind
of attic season so if you don't have you
know an avenue to like run through all
your data and give you a few results
with well it all kind of build up the
computation for mentally and tensorflow
on logistic regression but with wealth
and Excel a which is this Spencer host
specific compiler you know I'll perform
the standard cancer flow rather
substantially by around campus and well
that we competitive with Excel mates
before actually it's the specialized
compiler that Google has put out for
attention will actually put the even the
same reasons that well on this kind of
design so level is really competitive
with these domain-specific compilers as
well well really shines on this one time
every fourth or close however so we saw
this at the beginning of the talk is
that David
using peasant on high and here we see
180 SPF on false rights over to native
implementation by using libraries on
this workflow we're wiping some images
and then with a linear regression the
whitening happens in my mind when your
event happens as opposed to to credit
destroyed libraries by kind of looking
at the whole computation together and
optimizing over it device whatever it is
already and finally we also support kind
of treaty gaps so we have a small kind
of wrapper that maps like Scala
functions to log functions so this is
evaluating a small media model using a
scholar give me a spark and generating
native code for that data and finally
this is just looking at the effect of
incremental interpretation
so here we're just supporting one
Operator at a time for this black
Scholes workflow and kind of the
takeaway here is that the more operators
are implemented the better your
performance does when you still get
these incremental gains when you go out
but important kind of one Operator at
time it's just kind of some evidence
said you don't have to like take your
entire you know application and port it
over and do the incremental we can
evaluate whether you know intimate
intellect okay so I'm gonna switch over
to a demo now
[Music]
to
[Music]
can people see this okay yeah for this
world look is basically winter violin
one of the pandas tutorials so all the
tutorial is do it's doing is it's
cleaning something so it's similar to
the example that I showed a bunch of
slides before so I said the main
function so we're just thinking some
some values in a data frame and we're
slicing them placing some values here
and there's a number of operators here
so think about what happens in canvas
you're right here and I'm slicing each
of these things you're spending some of
them to zero then you're kind of doing
this mask saying them to man then
telling the unique things and a handful
of operators and the hope is that I kind
of using weld and fusing them together
we get
[Music]
all right so there's I'm doing pretty
well by negative kind of like fur okay
so then took around 12 seconds to write
about 246 using circles okay so now
we'll run this with with grizzly so all
the gear is I think important is grizzly
different thing it's just someone who's
less of a private variable and I'm just
wrapping the interpreting here this
should not be every well so if you look
calling the exact same function so we
haven't changed the function that we're
running at all we were just wrapping the
needle Frank and Chris be different
it'll go ahead and that took around two
and a half seconds okay so now we can
actually about this multiple threads
remember that grizzly need her and as a
Tiffany's a single threaded framework
these are kind of an invisible speed up
forgetting so I mean threads we do this
in less than a sec
so we're over 10x faster than what is it
all right
okay so it'll include kind of changing
that interface between libraries things
speed up analytics frameworks by you
know 10 to 100 X on modern hardware I
mean this is just by taking advantage of
the fact that you can look at the whole
program at once instead of you know
having to run each function call
individually if you're interested in
trying that well all of our code is open
source in there hit install these
frameworks or if you want to contribute
you